Bienvenidos a nuestro espacio económico
de France 24 hoy nos acompaña Jorge
Hurtado Jorge bienvenido Qué tal María
Clara todo muy bien y comenzamos con una
noticia Y es que varios países de
América Latina comenzaron a pagar en
yuanes sus importaciones Qué son esos
países y cuáles son las implicaciones de
esto María Clara los casos recientes nos
remiten a países como Argentina Bolivia
y también Brasil pensé que estos países
hablan de una reconfiguración del
sistema financiero global y de la
pérdida de confianza en el dólar algunos
de ellos atraviesan graves crisis
cambiarias y encuentran en la moneda
china una alternativa para frenar la
fuga de dólares el último en sumarse a
esta tendencia fue Bolivia ahí el
presidente Luis Arce argumentó que la
falta de dólares en el mundo y Por ende
en su país se debe a una disputa por el
control de la economía mundial entre
occidente y también el bloque liderado
por china Rusia e India pero para
entender que persigue Argentina y
Bolivia con el pago de transacciones
comerciales en yuanes conversamos antes
con Patricio housto director del
observatorio sino argentino y esto nos
dijo bueno dos cuestiones primero que
hay una tendencia global
impulsada por supuesto por china
buscando la internacionalización del
yuan que el Joan se convierta en una
moneda no solo de reserva que ya lo es
para algunos países justamente varios
países latinoamericanos y vos sino
también una moneda de intercambio
entonces Esto es algo Útil es una Es una
herramienta que Que obviamente en el
comercio exterior
es Es razonable sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que estamos hablando de países
que ya tienen a China como primer socio
comercial China la representa mucho para
el comercio de sus países con lo cual es
natural que esta moneda se incorpore en
el intercambio ahora bien veamos el
contexto justamente estamos hablando
recientemente de Bolivia y de Argentina
dos países que están atravesando serias
crisis cambiarias mucho más graves la
situación en Argentina un país que ya se
ha quedado también sin reservas en el
banco central y que depende cada vez más
del Swap el intercambio de monedas que
tenemos que es un intercambio ficticio
porque como Argentina ya no tiene moneda
el peso
literalmente dejó de existir con más del
100% de inflación es un préstamo
soberano que nos hace China y si cada
vez que nosotros lo usamos después eso
es deuda que se acumula bilateral Así
que son las dos cosas
internacionalización pero también países
que justamente atraviesan un contexto
para que esto prospere y Patricio nos
hablaba de Bolivia y Argentina que
fueron los casos que usted mencionó pero
China tiene una presencia en América
Latina cada vez más fuerte en los
últimos años y en ámbitos tan cruciales
como la inversión y también los
préstamos una investigación del centro
de pensamiento diálogo interamericano
reveló que bancos vinculados al Estado
chino han desembolsado más de 140 mil
millones dólares a gobiernos
latinoamericanos desde el año 2005 estos
préstamos se enfocaron en sectores como
la energía infraestructura y también la
minería y según ellos obedece a una
estrategia de Beijing para acercarse a
América Latina África y Asia uno de los
objetivos de su política exterior
consultamos con nuestro invitado sobre
la relevancia de mecanismos como el Swap
o el acuerdo de intercambio financiero
para países como Argentina y Bolivia
bien el Swap se volvió cada vez más
importante porque es básicamente la
única divisa que hoy dispone el Banco
Central argentino qué pasa por qué
todavía dispone porque china no
autorizado a usarla en su totalidad si
hubiese china autorizado esto yo se
hubiese evaporado en el marco de esta
crisis Argentina está por un lado
pidiéndole Diez mil millones de dólares
más al fmi por otro lado ahora como te
comentaba siete mil millones que nos
habiliten del Swap para poder usar a
China Entonces es un recurso cada vez
más invaluable y se ha prácticamente en
la última divisa en la última reserva de
Divisas que le queda a la Argentina
recordemos que no es fácil cambiar un
Joan a dólar hay que cambiarlo pagando
una tasa de interés muy alta
Generalmente esto se hace en bancos de
Hong Kong O sea no es un mecanismo tan
automático y sencillo y a China tampoco
le conviene que un país como la
Argentina empiece a exponer
internacionalmente el valor del yuan que
un país entre en default entre una
crisis profunda dilapidando sus yuanes
no es una buena noticia por eso china
apoya a la Argentina y probablemente
ahora no probablemente No ya está
confirmado lo va a hacer con Bolivia
también en este sentido habilitando este
mecanismo Pero cuidado vamos a ver en
función de cómo evolucionan estas crisis
Cuál va a ser la actitud de China
posteriormente Jorge yo me quedé con una
pregunta y es más allá de Argentina y
Bolivia Qué países están optando por
esta opción de los yuanes te voy a dar
un ejemplo el gobierno de Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva dispuso este año que
Brasil realice operaciones directas
entre el real y el yuan excluyendo el
dólar para febrero de este año el Joan
chino se convirtió en la segunda moneda
más presente en las reservas
internacionales del Banco Central de
Brasil incluso sobre el euro China y
Brasil acordaron recientemente hacer más
fácil el comercio y también las
inversiones bilaterales con sus
respectivas Divisas y de esta forma
reducir el uso del dólar en 2022 el
comercio entre el gigante asiático y
latinoamérica creció un 11% y se ubicó
en los 450 mil millones de dólares según
la oficina de estadísticas oficiales de
China esa cifra se podría duplicar en la
próxima década de acuerdo con expertos
en comercio exterior como La alemana
gtai según el fmi china será la
principal fuente de crecimiento Global
en los próximos cinco años un dato que
la región parece entender bastante bien
y también china ya consolidada como una
principal fuente de inversiones para la
mayoría de los países sobre todo en lo
que es infraestructura las grandes obras
y financista incluso hasta casi de
última instancia para un país como
Argentina vos Fijate en la situación a
la que estamos llegando no solamente
tiene suapa Argentina y otros países de
la región que han utilizado este
mecanismo Venezuela Ecuador en menor
medida Ecuador que ahora muy interesante
firmando un tlc el cuarto país de la
región en firmar un tratado de libre
comercio con China y reestructurando su
deuda toda esa deuda que se había
acumulado en la época de Correa y Lenin
Moreno el presidente lasso está
reestructurando la desde que asumió me
parece que ese es el camino un camino
mucho más correcto que el de seguir
endeudándose y empantanándose con
también con obras que no avanzan porque
ese es otro tema que estamos viendo en
la realidad de algunas obras de china en
la región Pero bueno sin dudas que la
presencia es importantísima va a seguir
creciendo Y por supuesto también a la
par como tú sabes preocupando los
Estados Unidos en lo que son los
sectores estratégicos Pues un tema
bastante interesante y pertinente Jorge
Gracias por todas las noticias
económicas la voz y nos vemos en la
próxima Por acá nos vemos y ustedes
sigan con Franz 24 porque tenemos más
información
[Música]